citizens of the recheck Nation we just
watched One Piece episode five now we're
about to watch One Piece episode six
Aaron how you feeling about it buddy I'm
feeling great Greg I'm loving it I can't
wait touch this leave a like on this
video people also subscribe click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for episode seven is up
here in the channel thank you to all who
have been watching with us it's been
such a great experience thank you to
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights and also massive thank you to
all who have joined our patreon page
becoming super sexy rejects over there
you can catch the full length Reaction
watch along with three sync up with your
own copy of one piece and we also cover
several shows over there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included thank you again to all
have joined let's watch this episode
[Music]
freakishly big
deal with anything sir hey can you hear
me where's the first aid kit do we even
sort of a first aid kit that scar looks
more pronounced than usual yeah I think
it's been getting more pronounced as the
episodes going on everywhere
you need a doctor that is the regret the
guilt of encouragement someone needs to
go back to variety I'm really not hungry
right now Nami not for food maybe one of
the customers is a ship's doctor I don't
know if you've noticed this but every
time like someone has colored eyes I
really really notice how dilated their
eyes are their pupils are huge so unless
you want to do brunch prep all by
yourself
way too runny God I'm so hungry right
now right same
[Laughter]
12. the nearest doctor is on economy
Island wait I'm waiting for your going
help tour boy's friend brunch is not
gonna prep itself you always told me to
defeat anyone who's hungry I don't see
how this is any different yes that's a
good heart love you Sanji bring me my
kitchen knives and a bottle of our best
whiskey and a fresh yellow towel and a
cooler bigger the better a Yellow Tail
just do it already Okay I thought he
said fresh yellow towel
chef's hat man
Chef Sanji and the eye is a knife
beautiful man
this is just making fish
oh he's making like a
patch or like a Band-Aid what the hell
stitching them together stitch them
together
[Music]
it's like absorb Simon's trick fish skin
now stunts the wounds Nails the Flesh on
the first one I'm gonna be doing that
from now on mayhawk
nice of you to announce yourself I
thought this was a conversation we might
have privately how does he travel
where's Luffy I decided to let him go I
specifically told you to bring him to me
well I don't take orders one of the
seven Warlords you serve I would still
do precisely what I want
is he a bad guy or is he just like more
morally ambiguous maybe your grandson
will be the one to follow the one piece
after all he knows grandson and just for
everyone to be hungry man plenty we
didn't use never waste food oh
I want sushi right same Jesus I'm really
[__] hungry same
not a joke right I'm really hungry it's
a problem
oh
I really gotta get the what aichi monkey
ready for him hey sword can you cook
sora's favorite food what about rice
will soaked beer I can make anything
just
tell me what you want dude this guy is
so naturally Charming being a captain is
the toughest job in the world so if once
told me that making decisions is what
separates a captain from the rest of his
crew amen and he was one of the best
pirate captains that ever sold the Seas
Seth was a pirate captain of the dreaded
cook Pirates
is to call him red leg zeph because his
boots were always stained with the blood
of his enemies how you two meet he was
captured backstory
nine years ago I will want to get to the
old blueberry it's a tall tale told by
Cooks to pass the time now get to those
tables
it's good I really believe the fear
he had both feet
damn the blood of his enemies
nice try a little eggplant they actually
want to die quickly slow who cares I'd
rather die than have you seated my food
that's not bad better than anything you
can make your own [__] bag you've got a
short time on you boy this is like
Star-Lord and yondu I picked you up as a
kid these boys wanted to eat you so you
tell me what does
I know I've been here
what happened
storm sung both our ships for the crew
They're All Dead oh wow to you guys huh
start a new father son what do we do we
white
oh wow did he lose his leg already
now
no no this is all the food we got
sorry slow you should be glad that I'm
giving you anything at all you could
have just killed him yeah don't you
bother me unless you see a ship you got
it
I'm gonna get down from there how's the
ship gonna
get you what's the logistics of that
are they not talking to each other at
all I guess not
just wait till he's starving seemed like
he's about to try to cook something
which I guess not
day 25
wow on that freaking Island huh no no
cover or I guess kind of cover
that's wild
[Music]
oh that must be the emphasis on why they
feed everyone
[Music]
um
the other one's big on charging but I
think that's why Sanji is huge on it but
now they yeah they both have hearts
five days after that why aren't they
bonding
this is I'd rather die than talk to you
kid
moldy bread we love moldy bread
good for the soul and the spirit it's
really capturing that Stark desolation
quite well yeah oh I feel you Sanji I
feel the same way how long you think you
would last on there a day a day
I'm stressed
50 days
that's a strong kid right there
real trial damn
what 70 days dude that's wild three
months and ten days of little food howdy
how how do you survive
I'll kill myself it took you 70 days to
get to that point
foreign
they start eating his own leg
oh he hasn't touched his food I told you
to stay cool you still have some food
oh it's just treasure oh he gave him all
the food oh wow
how are you still alive he did eat his
own life
[Music]
what happened I ate it boy a man's gotta
do what a man's Gotta Do
yeah did he do that without screaming
tough pirate you ate it you didn't save
me any he gave me all the food
why you don't even know me why would you
do that for stranger damn
harsh because we are napping on I have
been searching for the old blue my whole
life but now my time has come to an end
wow you share the same dream as me carry
it on believe me the old blue is real
and if I can't find him what in mind
that you can
so I'm gonna need you to live on you
have any idea what that's like having
someone lose a limb to save your life
actually I kind of too
we were out there for 85 days I'd eat
both arms and legs to say sora's life it
sounds like I don't know about all that
in a certain country in the northern
Seas they're doing the Marvel hero
healing thing I said they would do
sometimes when you are in charge you
have to make the tough decisions why
does everybody keep saying that because
you could have saved Zorro
I'd do anything to save him except stand
in the way of his dream but isn't there
something that you want not everyone
gets to follow their dreams it's a dream
Nami will help this whole episode's
about leadership you know Luffy is my
grandson it's my ears trying to build
him into a proper Marine
he is
Colby's
Kobe I was trying to make him his son I
spent time with Luffy Luffy is different
he thinks for himself no matter what
anyone else says because Luffy knows
exactly what he is pirate
how many assassins you sent after him
he'll never change he'd rather die first
and what do you suggest that I let him
be a damn full pirate that'd be the
worst thing sir accept things of
people's choices come on come on
you can get there maybe you're right
most of the Marines on Deck I'll address
them afternoon watch
is that the shark guy from a couple
episodes ago yeah I think so
wow what an entrance
I'm afraid there are no more tables
sit down
get comfortable it's up to you
let's all enjoy our last meal last meal
am I on this place well I'm our long and
I own the East blue no one owns a sea
well that's about to change once you
give me what I want what you want Luffy
looking for a pirate pirate and straw
hack goes by the name of Luffy everybody
wants
that's not familiar
look what his mustache moves when he
talks people already have a meal but if
you don't bring me the straw hat boy
before I finish maybe I might just start
adding some of these nice folks to the
menu everyone wants didn't Steph say
we're supposed to talk to him tell him
stories what would I say speak from the
gut
hey Zorro
[Music]
Luffy the harlong Pirates rapper audio
we have to leave now because they're
looking for you and the map you don't
need to be there all right I'm coming
with you all right kick some ass this
isn't your fight why would you do that
you fed us
bring your fight this is totally this
fight they're hunting again
you stay with the ship and protect the
map
be safe with you
thank God that's a complicated meal most
fishermen will be happy to sit at the
same table as a human fishermen are
superior to humans in every single way
faster
that dude is menacing I'm Monkey D Luffy
I hear you're looking for me the man I'm
looking for can you find me anyway oh
friend help me track you down
did you miss me
you don't even know how to find me I
told you I've got eyes and ears
everywhere
he never
wait no not back in the bag it's so dark
and wet and Sandy
and if you bow down to me I don't bow
down to any man or fish and you're no
King I will be when I get my grandmother
oh he's a warlord you're gonna have to
fight me for it to let the fighting
begin
[Music]
he didn't have a leg for a second
oh [__] yes
[Music]
he was warned about it yep
I think Zorro's going to come in at the
last second and kind of Save the Day
I love the makeup on him looks really
cool I told you in the bar I didn't have
any friends the truth is I couldn't let
myself have them why because I always
end up hurting the people closest to me
oh
You're In Cahoots with fish man is that
what the implication is well fish man's
there and she we don't know who she was
talking to of course she's gonna give
him a map to save Lucy
guys that was cool
to play on the music
come on man
[Music]
come on Luffy I really do appreciate the
stunt work in this show it's really
great
hey nice
yeah
how about a drink
sea water oh he knows all his weaknesses
[Music]
I thought it was being submerged just
literally just seawater touching him I
have the map
for you just like I said I would ah
you're right Aaron what are you doing I
tried to tell you Luffy I was never on
your crew I only joined up with you so I
could steal them out
she has been for years she's a pirate
you said you hated Pirates why waste
your time killing a devil fruit eater
Let the Sea do it for you
do not know how to swim no he can't be
in water at all
let's see the body shot body shot
she betrayed you guys man so much of the
question all the disillusionment that he
has to deal with
there's body shows for us I'm talking
about baby yeah gotta get that shirtless
shot
oh forgot about this
she's getting intense so what a mission
has changed no more half measures the
straw hats and their Captain Will Never
Surrender so the clubs are coming off
double down we will capture them
and they will be brought to Justice
I don't need you to do that we've got a
full house tomorrow two dinner seatings
I don't want to hear this what is your
problem you're the one with a problem so
get out of my restaurant now I've
already told you I'm not gonna be a
waiter you're not going to be anything
no if you stay here
he wants him to go on the adventure
moaning about your blue if it means that
much to you go go find it it's
a dream it
[__] maybe I take him up on that offer
you want my permission you got it [__]
fine fine
[Laughter]
the way the relationship is written so
tough it's such tough love
be like I care about you and we had a
pretty great dinner only I kind of
messed it up and now I lost Nami I lost
the Grant Line map and maybe I will lose
you too this is really important to have
for the character I didn't know what to
say before but I know what to say now
and it's so simple I need you Zorro
say something to Hero You're Gonna Keep
talking or let me get some sleep turtle
you acted like a captain but her crew is
falling apart I roro Noah sorrow about a
Stand By Your Side oh [__]
until the end yeah
until we find the one piece or die try
yes let's go so bring on the Marines or
Pirates or sea beasts or my captain
movie yeah I'm your first mate yeah
[Music]
I wasn't worried for a second
hahaha
what do we do now plot a course for the
ground line nope get Nami getting on my
back first
we're going after Nami and we need to
cook and we need a cook how did you guys
need a cook
yeah
yes we do
let's go welcome aboard
what are we bring in the waiter
you missed everything
[Laughter]
oh they ain't gonna have their goodbye
it's his son he didn't have a father boy
but I was always your daddy
[Music]
hey Sanji you keep your feet dry goodbye
zeph
you know all these years
living under your shitty roof cooking at
your shitty restaurant
I owe you my life
oh
thank you for putting up with my [__]
all these years old man
[Music]
I hope he sees that again in episode
823.
we're gonna find her and know someone
who does did you still buggy that's what
I'm thinking
yeah
what was that face
oh what a show so good
girl with the sawfish tattoo ooh okay
we'll learn about her next episode cool
is that not me
I'm gonna assume it was yeah
um well Aaron please
I'm on our six of filming today you
should go first okay well this episode
was Splendid it was awesome I think the
fact that you kind of spoke to something
a little bit earlier with them kind of
touching on leadership and what that
means whether it be from zeph or what it
means for Luffy to take out the mantle
of leadership
or you know what it means for um Luffy's
grandfather to take up or to to uh have
that role and then um Kobe kind of
falling into that that Junior role I
think it was something that was uh
prevalent throughout the whole thing and
you know we got to see Luffy really grow
in this episode really kind of
step a little bit out of that naivety
but still hold that sense of of
of drive and that positivity and that
belief in people even though Nami
betrayed them he still wants to do the
right thing he still sees the good in
her and he sees beyond the fact that
she's a traitor and he sees her heart
which I really resonated with uh yes
also everything with with Sanji and and
zeph seeing their relationship a dynamic
grow over the course of nine years I
thought that was very powerful and and
the show continues to do this thing
where it endears us to characters so
quickly within like has Cuts all the fat
and doesn't waste a single moment and
yeah by the end of it when sanji's
coming with the straw hat crew you you
feel that that kinship you feel that
relationship between the two and it's
bittersweet and it's really crazy
because granted we sell a little bit of
their relationship in the last one but
we really got to see it in this one and
yeah I think it just continues to do
what it does best
which is and dearest of characters show
us heart show us what Drive means show
us what family means and yeah it's by
the time we get to this episode it's
really rewarding uh not having Zorro in
it because it only makes everything
that's happened around it more
meaningful and the fact that he chooses
definitively to be with Luffy to be with
the straw hat crew to be his first man
um yeah everything we've been through up
to this point really makes that uh
satisfying
and I think the only thing I would say
is I feel like um not not it's not a
negative per se but it's kind of making
me question things the fact that what is
usab's role here really
um because Grant he has his
two episodes in there really good and
you really have to see his heart like
what he was about and his backstory and
everything but I don't know if he
contributed a whole lot and he's been in
this episode or the last episode
um
I guess that's to be seen as far as what
his ultimate contribution to this group
is uh he granted he provides laughs but
as far as like being a useful part of
the team I'm curious to see what
um what role he has also when I assume
they're gonna get Nami back what does
their Dynamic all look like as a team
with Sanji being the chef with Zorro
being The Swordsman usab is the wannabe
leader and and
um slingshot guy what the [__] what's
that role called I don't remember
um and and Luffy of course
and yeah what what does that definitive
family look like once they're all on the
same page once they're all chosen of one
another
uh yeah the fighting was great in this
episode the choreography the music was
great the the fish guys trap beats were
dope
yeah I I really enjoy this episode I
wouldn't say I loved it quite as much as
the last one but I think there was still
a lot of good here there's a lot of
ground work being Set uh going into
these next two episodes so yeah I it
shows continues to be great and I
continue to love it
Greg what did you think
this might be the first episode I didn't
like oh
that was great yeah
I thought it was great that was really
important Journey for Luffy especially I
think it's really
the same way how I thought it was
important for Zoro to lose I thought it
was really important for Luffy to lose
we need a Luffy to lose and so much has
been
uh pushed pushing Luffy up against the
wall and having him question his belief
system and
his dreams and how true to the path of
your dream how long can you stay the
course of being on your dreams yeah
in spite of everything that is to throw
in your way that's make you question
your whole belief system and I love what
I love what they did with Luffy here was
it's him fighting to maintain his
optimism
in spite of all that and all the
hardships thrown his way he still tries
to keep that chipper tone
you know like it it seems there's
something about the performance of Luffy
that it's not disingenuous it there
there's something performative but feels
intentional about the delivery like this
is the optimistic act that he has to put
on because like we've seen the times
where Luffy gets very sincere we've seen
the times where Luffy gets very serious
and Stern you know but then he's got
that very specific Cadence you know that
that that Joy so we're not seeing the
actors putting on the character Luffy's
putting that on yeah the actor as the
character yeah like the character is
putting on that certain type of cadence
um it's like he's had to adopt that
because he's not he wasn't that way when
he was like a little child or whatever
you know it's like it seems like that's
that was the performative part of him
that he had to put on you know and
I'm saying the character feels
three-dimensional because of it yeah you
know and I thought like here we were
appearing behind that performative side
of him and I thought that was really
important for this character to really
lose because we've seen him be pushed up
against the wall
have villains
um pose philosophical differences and he
still comes out the winner and I think
it's super important for his care Our
Heroes to experience loss so that way we
know they're not invulnerable I think
it's very key to rooting for our
characters and how it dovetailed into
Zorro
at the time when Luffy needed someone to
believe in him the most that's when
Zorro came to his you know
um
what is the word I'm looking for I don't
know just that that that unfleeting
loyalty to be his first mate to sort of
be like you are my captain to come
around to that
it affirmed that he's in the right role
that he's doing the right yeah staunch
loyalty uh is the word I'm looking for
they needed that and I thought that was
a great show the uplifting side of of
all them uh there's a really integral
part and to get the reveal on NAMI I
thought was was good it was good I do
and
instead of a bummer but it feels like
she'll come back around yeah she's gonna
come back around yeah how do you feel
about usop in this episode
I'm with you uh um like he gave them the
ship and I thought he was really great
in the couple episodes he was in
uh he's not particularly funny and
and he was a little bit
it wasn't like annoying or anything but
it was like you're just kind of there
yeah I I don't really know what he can
contributes I think he's supposed to be
there to just ask someone oh wait to see
a little bit I got two great episodes
where he was a focus and now it's like
two yeah it's kind of here
and
I wanted to be imported uh I want him to
feel very integral and and
um I liked the r long character
I got a question hmm
I know we make our little satirical
black guy jokes
um but I do have a sincere question
about it because I kind of noticed it
where it's like
it seemed like they were drawing an
allegory there's a guy who plays our
long I get the impression he's a black
guy yeah the yeah and they were making
like racial allegories
um with between like the the kind of
human society and how fish people are
treated you know what I mean yeah and I
feel like they would cast that's like
I kind of feel like that is a it's not
really a Christian it's really just a
pondering thought that I'm having
um that they would cast that character
like get a black eye to be that guy and
because my question is like how do you
feel about that like because it seems
like that would be like the yeah you
got usop who's not really feeling like
the most integral guy and then you got
the black guy being like the main
villain guy one of the main villain guys
for that kind of role and to me I'm like
I don't really have strong feelings
about it but it's just kind of another
thing I'm noticing
was the residential black man here at
the only one
no I thought that was an interesting
observation and you're like yeah no it
was even though he was under a ton of
makeup it was very apparent that that
was a black man playing that character
and um yeah no I definitely see the
parallels between like
you know these these fish people who are
representative of of black people
um being these these Pirates are like
The Outsiders of society and like it was
like something like um almost kind of
like Malcolm X in a way like I don't
know if he's Grand granted trying to
like
unite all fish people but I know he gave
the the guy who was the the host like
the side eye for for working for like
the man you know uh so yeah I think
that's a very interesting observation
um yeah I wasn't I wasn't something I
was actively thinking about as we were
watching it but
he's talking about it now like yeah I
definitely see those those Parallels for
sure
um that's why I brought you on for one
piece I heard about that there's one
Blackfish guys I just can't I just can't
comment on it for the black person and
black people love animes yeah
no yeah you all do
all of you people
God damn uh but no I think that's
interesting I wonder if they're gonna
take
this is why I'm here uh no wonder
they're gonna take that further or what
they're gonna do with that if they're
gonna explore that more in the the
future of the show whether it be the
last two episodes of the Season or be
the
God the entirety of the rest of the
series
who knows yeah you know maybe he'll uh
maybe he'll start a fish Revolution you
know maybe he'll
of a fish stream I think this show is
doing actually a great job I think this
Show's doing a great job on
um all it's I like I love the characters
I love Sanji I love the story of asanji
here and
it it feels like one of those
it feels like one of those things where
they take uh like going through the
flashbacks and such a unique story of
how they came to be and it was so visual
and mood and Atmospheric heavy
and then if so emotional at that goodbye
I think I think I think like those the
way those characters are drawn are
amazing yeah and I think the show does a
great job with
um diversifying its cast especially
and I guess I I am there going
it would be cool if they did get like a
truly great character who was a black
person in here you know what I mean I
would like but you know yeah okay just
waiting for him to see
yeah yeah because we got like this whole
this whole main cast it seems like
there's such a rich diversity and I'm
not really one who like
like I love diversity but I don't really
like fight for diversity you know I'm
not like one who's who's like a one more
diversity although he would but I don't
really I guess I don't really like
exclaim about that or Proclaim for he's
not Captain diversity I'm not
um but when it's there and it's good I
like it you know and I guess like with
seeing just how great they are with the
diversity so far
it was I think that's what Drew my
attention to it was like okay it seems
like we and unless we're wrong because I
got the black guy being the villain
under the makeup player that kind of
character
now you got usapu they don't really know
what to do with in the last couple of
episodes right so I think that's what
was drawing I was trying to question I
was questioning like why am I thinking
about it um so I would want to see that
sort of be enhanced we'll see still got
two episodes left yeah and then you know
500 more episodes
I'm still curious to know how they got
saved off of that weird Island they were
on
because I'm like that seems like a weird
predicament it ran out of budget they
ran out of budget like all right they
will go today and 85 they saved us
that's all you need to know that's
important yeah
but I like I also love the how how and
I'm sure the anime uh
does this really well it with the
fighting style of how they've managed to
uh really distinguish the different
fighting styles clearly yeah yeah like I
love Sanji being mainly like a kickboxer
kind of guy yeah the fact that they made
a guy who only kicks look good and like
I can't wait until the show has like
their Avengers shot of all of them doing
their individual fighting styles
together that can be so cool we haven't
really got to know nami's too well but
what I love about song I just love that
they brought that aesthetic to life of
like him walking around and constantly
with his hands in his pockets I'm like
God damn yeah you're just seeing that
kind of character so much it's so cool
yeah I will say something else that's
been something I've appreciated has been
watching is the fact that you know
normally when you're watching like
cartoons or animes they usually have the
same outfit for every single episode and
I like that the show has Diversified
their outfit but yet each variation of
their outfits feels very true and
authentic to each of these characters
yeah and thematically similar in spite
of the fact that they're literally
different clothes yeah yeah that's very
true
all right man that was great I'm loving
the show like two episodes left two
episodes left for the last two and the
channel dies
[Laughter]
it's over guys there's nothing else to
look forward to and the views are low
fear every week oh God yeah we're still
still we're still kicking strong all the
time
no man challenge been great
um all around and thank you guys for
being here
I appreciate you but before we head out
first leave a like leave a comment
make it all about those the black people
thing we talked about and then uh
for those that stayed for the racial
commentary we appreciate you subscribe
ring that Bell as Tara likes to say and
hey let's um end this with a patron of
the day shout out we're gonna round
through this with Rocket Baby pandemic
Jones
home time for pandemic Jones okay don't
botch this I'm a freestyle is that we're
doing here I'm just doing it just do
some rhymes
shouting out pandemic Jones
pandemic Jones over here as we shout
them out on the real Rejects
yeah you appreciate this channel we love
you
this isn't a rhyme this is just coming
from the heart that's just how I start
this is what I do this is my art
pandemic Jones you're the man and I know
you understand what we do here at the
real rejects is for you
for your views
for your heart and we love you too
just like you love us
me and him
watching One Piece
that's what we do that's it that's all
that's all I got
it wasn't much but it it's what it
happened it wasn't much indeed
it was you had something better
come on rhymes
foreign
[Music]